So, whether you’re looking for garden tools
for yourself or someone else who may have
some gardening accessibility issues, there
are a variety of tools on the market
these days.
One of the early ones that came out were tools
that had these arched handles to them.
And they give a little bit more leverage for
people who may have arthritis or some mobility
issues in their hands and their wrists.
There are some more tools on the market now
that have a longer handle to them so they
could be used from a wheelchair or from a
standing point.
And they also have extendable handles.
There are also some hand tools that you can
use on the ground that will give you accessibility
into shrubbery that’s oftentimes difficult
to get into.
And then we also have watering tools that
will help you reach plants to water them either
from a standing or a sitting position, or
to reach plants that are overhead and to make
sure that you can get water to them.
Many different garden centers will carry different
brands and different accessibility tools,
but you can ask them to shop for them.
We also have a publication that was put together
by one of our retired specialists just a few
few years ago.
And if you’re looking for tools for accessibility
you can also order some of them from suppliers
online.
With the university of Wyoming Extension,
I’m Donna Hoffman, From the Ground Up.